ik HEB maar 30 seconden
voorzitter de hersteloperatie
toeslagen zal herstel
moeten bieden aan gedupeerden van 1 toeslagaffaire
niet alleen financieel
ook emotioneel
maar het lukt ons niet
om 1 hersteloperatie
in te richten waar ouders en kinderen ook dat herstel
geboden wordt
dat zien we allemaal en nog belangrijker
dat hoor van heel veel ouders
het onlangs verschenen berichten over
CBS was bij de Wilde konijnen af
om maar bij hun eigen bewoording te blijven voorzitter
CBS
ik kan gewoon niet begrijpen dat de kamer al jaren
al jaren aangeeft dat de zoon niet werkt
dat we hier als kamer
zelf ook nog 1 extra
onderzoek hebben laten uitvoeren door audinstrijk
en dat bericht in de krant
de commissie
zegt nu zelf dat de afhandeling van zaken te langzaam
gaat
buiten we als kamer voldoende door
ik vraag het me iedere keer af
naar ieder debat en naar iedere motie
we zien dat sommige ouders nog meer beschadigd
raken dan ze al waren
omdat het hersteltraject op allerlei manieren
tekortschiet met als
ramp naar ramp voorzitter
toch 2 moties
de kamer gehoord
de beraadslaging
overwegende dat de brede ondersteuning en antwoord
op de vraag wat ouders
nodig hebben voor 1 nieuwe start
bij gemeentes
soms goed verloopt
maar in veel gevallen van ouders tot frustratie leidt
overwegende dat kinderen
zich in veel gevallen niet melden bij de gemeente
terwijl er meer kinderen gedupeerd zijn
om ouders verzoekt de regering
op zeer korte termijn
te verduidelijken wat ouders en kinderen
kunnen verwachten van de gemeente
en hierbij ouders en kinderen te betrekken
zodat hun perspectief centraal staat
verzoekt de regering
voor gedupeerde kinderen 1 meldpunt in te richten
dat aansluit bij de belevingswereld van jongeren
zodat we ze beter in beeld krijgen en kunnen helpen
en gaat over tot de orde van de dag
de kamer gehoord de beraadslaging
overwegende tot 26 oktober 2023
motie 31 066 streepje 13 12 is ingediend en aangenomen
met betrekking tot de trage werkwijze bij CBS
overweeg dat hierin wordt verzorgd
de capaciteit
van CBS binnen 6 maanden opgeschaald hebben naar 15
dossiers per week
en wanneer dit niet lukt
de capaciteit
voor de ontwikkeling van de maatwerkroute in te zetten
overwegende dat je ongekend
onrecht niet oplost met bureaucratische processen
maar met mensen die in contact met mensen
bereid zijn tot ze komen tot oplossingen
verzoekt de regering
bij de aanstaande herinrichten van CBS deze motie
uitgangspunt te nemen
waarbij de ouders regie hebben over hun eigen proces
en aannemelijkheid van het verhaal van de ouder
het uitgangspunt wordt
en gaat over tot de orde van de dag
mede ingediend door de Heer stiltjes